Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
Henry requested today that I make a video
about dragons and dinosaurs where they fight
together against bad guys and there are scary
parts, but not too many scary parts.
And I then explained to him that sadly I can
only make videos where my head moves around
a screen.
BUT if there are any brilliant video editors-slash-motion
graphics artists out there in Nerdfighteria,
please take this idea and run with it.
So, since I can't make a video with dinosaurs
and dragons where they fight together against
bad guys, I'm going to make a video about
the future of Nerdfighteria.
So, Hank, every year we have this huge Nerdfighter
gathering at VidCon and we talk about what's
ahead for Nerdfighteria, and I thought I'd
share some of the things that came out of
that discussion.
One, we wanna do more IRL events.
Hank, you're on tour right now and you're
having a great time; we wanna do more of that.
It's a bit difficult for me to travel right
now because family, but a) we wanna do more
Nerdfighter gatherings that we're a part of,
and b) we wanna facilitate Nerdfighter gatherings
that don't include us.
I mean, the Internet is great and everything,
but nothing beats real life, I mean, except
for the Internet, the Internet does beat real
life, but real life is a close second.
Two, Hank, we wanna make educational video
for younger people.
I don't think I'm allowed to say anything
more about that just yet, but wouldn't it
be great if elementary school students had
video that got them excited about like, science
and history and also gently introduce them
to the idea that dragons and dinosaurs did
not technically co-exist?
Three, non-video educational materials to
go with CrashCourse.
So, Hank, CrashCourse is used in thousands
of schools, which is great, and we hear from
lots of teachers and students that they would
love, like, essays and primary sources and
worksheets and other stuff to go with the
videos.
Khan Academy has helped us out with that some,
link in the doobly-doo, but we'd like to do
much more of it in the coming year.
Four, decreasing worldsuck and increasing
world awesome year-round.
So, Hank, the Project for Awesome is amazing.
Last December we raised more than 800,000
dollars for charity, but we'd like to do more
of that stuff year-round.
Speaking of which, why am I wearing a Brazil
jersey?
Well, because with matching donations, Brazil
fans have donated more than 16,000 dollars
to Sarcoma research to win my World Cup affection.
And overall, Hank, that project has now raised
more than 80,000 dollars for the Sarcoma Foundation,
I mean, I do not need any more potassium today,
because that is bananas.
Anyway, we wanna do more of this kinda stuff.
Five, advertising.
So, Hank, we've never run pre-roll ads on
Vlogbrothers because we find pre-rolls annoying;
instead, we have these display ads that are
like, here, and e--I don't, I don't, I'm not
good with directions.
But now that pre-roll ads are like, 99% of
YouTube's revenue, Vlogbrothers, I'm not allowed
to say actual numbers, but it could generate
like, five or six times more money than it
currently does.
So, we're wondering a) if we should that,
and b) how?
Here are some options: keep it like it is,
delete ads entirely from Vlogbrothers, start
using pre-rolls and donate all the money to
the Foundation to Decrease Worldsuck, start
using pre-rolls and put all the money into
education and nerdfighter projects.
Like, Hank, many years ago, you bought Vi
Hart a bunch of equipment so that she could
make better videos more often.
That was super cool of you, but it also turned
out to be like, the best $1,000 you ever spent,
because Vi Hart went on to be this phenomenally
successful educational creator.
So we could use the money to do way more stuff
like that and plus fund other Nerdfighter
projects, or we could do some combination
thereof.
Nerdfighters, this is something we really
wanna hear from you about, so there is a survey,
link in the doobly-doo, where you can also
talk to us about like, what you'd like to
see from Crash Course and education content
on YouTube in general.
And lastly, Hank, you know how we sponsor
this amazing soccer team, AFC Wimbledon?
Well, thanks to fans of the hankgames channel,
we've been able to increase our sponsorship
so that next season, we're gonna be on their
shorts.
You heard me right, Hank, this design is going
to be on the shorts of the actual AFC Wimbledon
uniforms.
And, Hank, this also means that when you play
as AFC Wimbledon in FIFA 15, you will see
this on their computer shorts.
That's right, Nerdfighters, we did it.
We made it to FIFA!
So, Nerdfighters, those are some of our thoughts
on the future of Nerdfighteria, please let
us know where you'd like it to go in comments.
DFTBA, Hank, I will see you on Friday.